makaay la haine gabe la journaliste et
blogueur tchadien c'est lui d'ailleurs
ce matin
[Musique]
bonjour mac et la haine des blâmes merci
beaucoup d'être ce matin en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors il ya une
manifestation cet après-midi à paris
pour demander à ce que la france arrête
de soutenir ou de fournir en tout cas
des renseignements à l'armée tchadienne
pour pour défendre le président au
pouvoir il ya une récente incursion
expliquez-nous ce qui s'est passé merci
bonjour madame
effectivement ce qui s'est passé c'est
aussi la coordination des deux facteurs
endogènes d'avoir la crise libyenne
parce que il ya eu un accord de paix
entre les belligérants livia et l'appui
la piste inter c'est la crise en
deuxième
parce que monsieur débit depuis 31 ans
au pouvoir
ces puits à cristalliser les pollutions
garde-fous sont démocratisés menacé
l'opposition armée qui a décidé de faire
une incursion comme l'avait dit sur le
territoire tchadien donc depuis lundi le
roi en mouvement le fac le franc ou la
maintenance et la compare aux cadres
avec des quads des centaines de prendre
a fait son incursion sur le territoire
tchadien et des attaques des villes du
nord sont tombés en faveur de ces
groupes rebelles notamment la ville de
moore la ville de doké
la ville d'ottawa est encerclée par
l'armée tchadienne sa colère noire part
par les éléments des fat donc la
situation extrêmement grave c'est qu'ils
particulier dans cette affaire c'est
aussi la culture c'est l'ingérence de la
france dans cette affaire
dans ce conflit tchadien cet instant à
cet âge a été bouclée depuis 2006 des
mérites des midinettes et même en
janvier 2021 donc la présence militaire
de la france inquiète parce que l
enseigne les positions rebelles au
profit de l'armée intervient ça veut
dire par sa ville qui soutiennent de
guerre et paris est en train de déposer
dans un conflit qualité malgré malgré un
communiqué de presse du quai d'orsay
les cadets ne sont pas rassurés rade
parce que pour vous le le pouvoir en
place
si terne serait incapable d'arrêter ces
colonnes qui essayent régulièrement de
faire des incursions sur le territoire
tchadien
elle sera incapable de le faire sans
l'aide de la france depuis toujours on a
constaté un 2006 lorsque le filtre le
froid ni le changement avait fait son
nid question depuis les territoires des
piles est du tchad du scandale et la
débilité pratiquement des faits et il a
fallu que l'armée française sous jacques
chirac bombarde la colonne rebelle en
2008 paraît des vétérans c'est
totalement secret il a fallu que nicolas
sarkozy intervienne pour repousser les
rebelles en 2019 c'était pareil lui de
l'union pour l'union des forces de la
résistance ufr qui a fait cinq ans
qu'ils sont de pires la frontière tchado
ligue 1 aujourd'hui en 2020 terre c'est
aussi l'armée tchadienne est
complètement défaite parce que je dirais
ya un problème interne au tchad
il a fallu que deby celui ci arrive
cette fois ci cette phase il est
présentement en tout cas l'armée
tchadienne telle que nous la connaissons
elle est incapable de faire face à des
mouvements rebelles tchadiens
si elle fait face à des groupes
terroristes à l'étranger elle est
incapable de continuer à l'ancienne et
le problème qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est le soutiennent militaires
diplomatiques et et politique de la
france qui inquiète l'opposition
démocratique qui inquiète la cité civils
qui inquiète également nous autres des
la diaspora c'est qui explique aussi
notre mobilisation en france en tant que
réfugiés politiques mais surtout que
l'opposition on en parlant puisque
récemment il ya eu des élections
présidentielle et l'opposition a du mal
à émerger
le patient a dit mme à un objet parce
qu'elle est contenue par une répression
violente des consignes et de la part des
forces de l'ordre mondial parce que vous
savez dans ces pays depuis 30 ans il
nous a été totalement interdit de
manifester dating organisé des réunions
pacifiques
donc pour lui cette proposition apple
côté qu on vous l'avait dit madame
l'élection à la prétendue est riche en
gaz est parée du débit qui ne fait que
regarder d'épidémie ciel des électeurs
qui le remporte avec un score fleuve
donc la question est le peuple c'est à
dire écoutez c'est un signal fort s'est
déshabillé que nous avons eu nous avons
inscrit à l est du délit qui devrait
plutôt tiré la leçon de ses 17 de son
impopularité maintenant certains menace
et c'est l'aspect international qui nous
l'équipe c'est aussi le positionnement
de leurs partenaires internationaux
cuniculiculture kimono pour comment vous
expliquez ce soutien indéfectible de la
france à idriss deby vous savez madame
monsieur deby arrivé au pouvoir en
disgrâce au à la france dans quoi
c'était sous mitterrand et donc depuis
lors la france qui avait à l'époque
demandé aux états 15 d'organiser à faire
des conditionnels république directement
par la démocratie des picards en lice
ainsi concerne les cadres malgré que
l'accord national était un baiser la
france n'a pas soutenir les démocrates
et rien d'autre son obsession j'ai tiré
de soutenir et du défi sous le prétexte
que cet homme est un allié fidèle à
paris il n'est pas pour nous il n'est
pas non plus pour incertaine ne parlera
pas encore montées intéressantes qui est
beaucoup plus tôt attentive dans nous
avons toujours décrié le soutien massif
que paris a pas qu'en fermant totalement
les médias les médias français à des
provinciales en fermant totalement
effectivement l'accès au quai d'orsay à
des opposants à un format totalement
l'accès à l'assemblée nationale à deux
enseignants
ça nous inquiète énormément dans nous
parlons pas natif de la forme d'un coup
elle nous accueille chez elle par mois
je suis fier politique j'ai été acquis
en 2013 de manière officielle par
l'accord du présent hollande
il avait demandé à la france de
reconsidérer sa politique au tchad nous
constatons début 2013 alain jeu depuis
que je suis sur le territoire français
je constate malheureusement que la
france continue à soutenir une dictature
qui est dangereux parce qu'il me semble
la seule condition et demander la
démocratie 6-2 tout le reste est
d'autoriser les manifestations
pacifiques
on sait qu'à la france n'est pas la
passe tout ni non plus malgré qu'elle a
une présence pas renié on a souhaité que
la présence de l'armée française aurait
aidé à la conception de l'état du droit
à la construction d'une démocratie
effective plus au tchad malheureusement
nous ne comprendrons tandis
qu'aujourd'hui
l'attitude est l'obsession de la france
dernière question est ce que justement
la situation géopolitique et la crise au
sahel 1 n'est pas un début d'explication
pour ce soutien et idriss deby qui
serait le seul capable en tout cas de
participer à cette lutte antiterroriste
le sel qui a bon dos d'ailleurs pour
aller chercher aussi les opposants
tchadiens sur le territoire libyen
madame toute attaque et sir est tout à
fait légitime affectivement à l'affice
au sel n'est pas
granger à la situation interne aucun de
nous ne pensons pas que l'armée
tchadienne qui est aussi que si je
dirais opérationnel au cnn et les ports
audio pâtissier la même année si jamais
la comédienne dans la seule ville à
travers la france pense qu'il faut c'est
elle
il ya des vélos sans droits de l'homme
il ya des pêcheurs il ya l'insécurité
elle aurait dû aussi penser du côté de
cas où cet homme-là rapidement son
peuple depuis 30 ans dans laquelle dix
scènes ne peut pas être à mon avis un
alibi est fondamental pour soutenir une
dictature contre une population
pacifique façon pas nous ne comprenons
pas la lecture effet les questions de
défense sur la question iranienne depuis
une trentaine d'années merci beaucoup
marqué la haine des plages rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et blogueur
tchadien merci beaucoup pour avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france